you know very often people tell me pap
you have no idea hungry i'm i'm the
hungriest i've ever been oh my gosh i'm
the hungriest person you'll ever meet
last week we have a conference call zoom
and just
two days ago yesterday had a meeting
over here in gaylord with 500 of our
guys that flew from all across the
country
and i asked the question i said how do
you measure hunger
and people said you know somebody who's
focused somebody who's clear
somebody who's this somebody who's that
i said you have no idea how much for me
it's so important to identify exactly
what's the number one thing
to measure the hungriest person in the
room number one thing
to measure the hungriest in the room not
number two thing
not number three think for example i was
lazy as a kid growing up my dad would
say why are you so lazy why are you so
lazy why are you so lazy
so i studied the topic of laziness why
are some people lazy because their life
is boring they don't have a
target they don't have something they're
going after right so laziness
is stemmed from boredom right if you
look at bitter people why are some
people bitter
why why are they so bitter because
they're not creating anything
they're not building something new
they're not crystal they get bitter
and upset and agitated about everybody
else that's trying to create something
right
element of bitterness is they're not
creating they're in a
state where they're no longer building
anything well how do you measure
somebody that's the hungriest
you know what's the number one way you
measure somebody that's hungry
very simple their sense of urgency
that simple let me explain to you why
so people say wow you have no idea
hungry i am really
yeah what you do about it today oh not
today but tomorrow
you ain't hungry man you just think
you're hungry you are
not hungry you may be hungry to go eat
lunch you may be hungry to go have
dinner fine i'll give that to you
you ain't hungry to compete in a
marketplace because a person who's
hungry
this is how they work i was watching an
interview earlier
of musk years ago he said i don't
recommend you wanting
to be like me he says because you don't
know how many hours i work
you don't know what it's like to be
thinking about wanting to win you don't
know what it was like every night going
to sleep
you know thinking tesla's about to go
out of business when people say
hey you think tesla stock's going to go
down it's going to go up it's going to
go
it's going to go down it's going to go
up but as long as
musk is behind it he is so flipping
hungry which is urgent he's so urgent
about
executing things now that no matter what
he touches
it's gonna grow because today he's
hungry this may change 10 years from now
this may change 20 years from now but
he's so hungry today and you cannot be
hungry
without being urgent so let me go back
to you right now if you said pat i'm
really hungry
fine what are you urging about what
question are you trying to get the
answer to right now
what person are you trying to contact
and get a hold of right now
if they don't answer the phone what is
your method of getting a hold of them
one time i had a guy that came up to my
office
and he was a magazine guy he comes
upstairs he says yeah let me tell you
i'm this guy this year this company
and you know i just kind of want to drop
off and i blew him off i'm like who is
this guy i honestly i'm so
busy i don't have time for you right now
it's good maybe i'll follow up with you
and uh this was in woodland hills in my
office uh at uh
a woodland hills marriott right right
next to woodland hills marriott warner
center marriott
so he leaves i look at his magazine and
i'm like oh shoot i didn't even ask for
his number he just gave him his bags
i'll go oh my gosh
she would disguise that so i said okay
let me send an email didn't respond back
let me send him in this i'm gonna try to
catch him before he comes up
doesn't let me send it as facebook
doesn't answer oh my god where is this
guy i'm looking outside
let me go on instagram i sent a message
to him in five six different platforms
he finally said i got he says come back
up i didn't know who you were i want to
talk to you
he comes back up i was going to get a
hold of the guy in that minute
because i needed him back in the office
that's the urgency part
i'll call him tomorrow it's a done deal
tomorrow
it's dead tomorrow may never happen
may now the deal that you were gonna
close may never
happen because you wait until tomorrow
so 2021
i can guarantee you one thing anybody in
your circle
that has been the same person if you
look at any of your best friends that
you've been hanging out with they've
been the same
if one of them changes and by the end of
2021 you say hey man
what happened to you something different
about you he or she may not even know
what changed
but i can guarantee you what change
about them that they may not even know
they became more urgent because hungry
people who are truly hungry
they're just more urgent than everybody
else
in the game period if i need to learn a
skill set today
i'm going to go buy the course today i'm
going to get better at it today
not tomorrow not this afternoon not
later on tonight today
i just had a meeting right now uh how
many hours of sleep am i going out right
now okay i mean
what's three or four hours of sleep for
me this weekend we went
last night we were up god knows to what
time some stuff happened last time we're
having a good time at
this place here in the uh plano and
frisco
i trained non-stop my voice is a little
bit raspy i trained non-stop on sunday
because we had our guys flowing this
week
and we were going to do the meeting we i
wanted to do it
early some why what are we doing next
week on a weekday
i said why don't we are you guys willing
to have this sales meeting on a sunday
pat are you willing to do it i'm willing
to do it so rather than making a meeting
on monday tuesday
we had the meeting sunday and monday
because i wanted to have the meeting
asap and we couldn't do it on the first
or the second because of events that we
had going on with everybody else that
was doing their sales meeting so the
earliest we could do was sunday
you know what happened today i'm over
here the running we had the podcast this
morning 7 30 i have to prepare for the
notes of the podcast before doing the
podcast
i have one meeting right now here i
asked the guy where are you at here's
what i got going on
uh i want to meet with you when right
now
can i come tomorrow let's meet right now
oh my god what do you got going on
because i
haven't seen my kids but i want to meet
with you right now all right i'm coming
by
he's right there right now he's my is he
not here right now my meeting's right
there right now
because i am urgent about getting
prom solved now so my business plan is
going to be hit whatever numbers i got
in place
it's going to be hit because i want to
get things done now
that's the element of being urgent you
go and assess all your friends and your
family and decide who's the hungry
you'll say oh my gosh this makes so much
sense pat
you know what that one guy in my life he
freaks like this
all the time and he is so flipping
urgent about things
exactly that's how you determine who's
the hungriest
so if you're watching this yourself and
you're saying you know what
i think i'm pretty hungry show it with
your urgency and if you want to find out
the mindset of somebody
that's hungry and urgent even if you've
already watched the interview
go watch it again especially since this
anniversary is coming up
go watch the interview with kobe bryant
and see what his mentality was like
as an urgent hungry guy that wanted to
get better
constantly faster and more efficient
than his peers
no wonder he won five championships
played with one team
for 20 years and god knows how many
records he broke having said that
i hope you're hungry and i hope you show
it by being urgent
this week take care everybody
[Music]
you